lt ragazzi e benvenuto questo video sono
fa vj into the way back quindi file
sweet sasha bella ragazza
vi lasciamo al video che quindi si è
ritrovato la testa come rimasta pagarlo
e stato questo a pie crepa bastardone
lista degli addetti ragazzi sono video
sono vari generi siamo di uno con mister
sa abbiamo sculacciato una tipa
l'abbiamo punita l'abbiamo messa qui
bene con che ragazzi abbiamo finito lì
fugge questa qua che quella più grossa
abbiamo dall'effige grossa che questa e
le fiji grossa ma arriverò a giovani che
coma anche tu lo vedi che ti portiamo
questo cosa più giri su chi si muove e
tipo gioco della bottiglia dai ma perché
sono sempre io prete che lo dimostra
come giocare gioca anche le azzurre una
bottiglia o di riguardo che a lei tocca
a lei allora ascolta un secondo il
nostro obiettivo adesso sono due abbiamo
due obiettivi allora il primo di finire
recinto il villaggio però siccome ci
mettiamo una vita e mezza a tirare giù
alberi e robe un più proporre col
secondo obiettivo quando quello di
andare in exploration kocic cela fiori
dobbiamo fare un feroce porca [ __ ] ho
visto il fuoco su un [ __ ] a fare o
grande male finita ma guai ma non l'ho
messa io qui cos'è la messa questa cosa
serve per raccogliere l'acqua quando
piove così beviamo un lago
va bene il nostro obiettivo in questo
momento è quello di trovare una [ __ ]
caverna perché nella caverna ci stanno
le corde e dove ci sono le corde abbiamo
le funi e sappiamo le funi andiamo nella
voragine di enorme dell'altra volta che
c'è una casa perché non ci sia nessuno
perché forse mentre questa cosa ora qua
in teoria dove ci sono le capanne a
volte non sempre c'è un qualche cosa che
ti fa andare giù poi ecco l'hanno
trovata lo sapevo c'è la caverna sua
caverna e se la caverna c6 arrivo arrivo
ok il concerto è arrivato un tipo però è
cazzo giù nella caverna giocare bene
cosa ma se devo ascoltare ad ora ma
cos'è eccole qua ho trovata vieni vieni
giovini giu intanto ti dò tutto giu
seguimi in viaggio verso l'ignoto a dio
ti ringrazio ce l'abbiamo fatta
e stato orribile c'è un cadavere era
visto girato qualcuno fa bene c'era un
tizio a conoscenza con lui ecco mi devi
dare una medicina se ce l'hai
tieni come che si preannuncia però
aspetta che ho paura di mangiarla e
invece ok perfetto game grazie
che colpa se la data quale la sainas al
posto della ri della lasagna tiera bava
sticca io non ho mai visto una caverna
così brutta impartendo ad avere tutte si
sino è terrorizzante vieni perferi
andiamo allora per noi su paura poi c'è
paura viene fatto io davanti si sta roba
ho trovato una bussola per stare buco
per terra
non lo so però è la mappa ho trovato la
mappa della della caverna perfetto così
possiamo tornare indietro e già intesa
quale atmosfera
allora vediamo una mappa dei parchi a
buttare perché buttare c'è gente c'è
liberamente sì c'è uno non so se mai
visto vai avanti con la birra quella
esatto fagli vedere di fare una scelta
che volevano ad usarla ciao zio accetta
l'amicizia accetta a varare il film fa
brutto ma che cazzo guarda che vara
lentini di andare un attimino avanti a
vedere che cosa c'è e quando vediamo il
pericolo assurdo torna hawaiano che yes
tensione ci sono i pipistrelli guai a
bio pero ci si va solo
guarda come promette bene questa entrata
vieni è un po come lucio con scritto
welcome welcome lo teniamo intorno al
fuoco di positivo c'è motivo la danza
della pioggia mln piove dentro la
caverna cuciniamo subito ex cookson
fucking aiuto aiuto l'acqua eccola qua
acqua ma qua qua ma inizio e tengono
infuocato si assistono i focato sono
infuocatissimo ok ha smesso e siamo
andati troppo ad uso e cazzo vai vai vai
moltissimo portò gli abbia viste tutta
la mia fiducia nell'africa ovvero
cos'era quella fare lì ma santo di dio è
un modo no ma più che altro perché
c'erano bambini morti ovunque con la
mono d'occhio c'è la molotov
devi dire è sorriso gli assi nella
manica per 84 di romiti se vuoi che
abbiamo fatto ma che chiedano avrei
preso st dinamite vera impresa se la fa
questa cosa
ll per non fare non lo fare non lo fare
perché la dinamite era alla miccia non è
che esplode quando la lancia ok per
quello che fai di rumore al cielo
dinamite spenta
andiamo dinamite evo e molotov c6
facciamo al presti sto bastardo
andiamo a farlo a pezzi ma vj e sunshine
avevi bari together control è parlato di
un po sì esatto ecco sono tornato dove
l'ho visto la prima volta che qua ci
sono bambini per scomparso che schifo la
soffitti sono feticisti ho sentito un
rumore dove dove arriva arrivare io lo
sento
arriva da qualche parte subito a
calcetto si no non ancora lo ceda
accediamo mangiamo non l'hai per niente
preso ma sono bambini
i bambini
io non ho paura o cose ma no vabbè se
salta quale ha chiesto cosa qua se
colpisci il ragno lo amassi subito
un'altra sino al 3 2 e vite bambine vita
bambini ecco cosa fissaggio titolo
capito aiuto ma spara spara della notte
a cesa ce l'ho spinto casa.it
lode a dio poi de ski
gli ho dato fuoco brucia ok un'altra
molotov all ultima poi chiarito agli
idealisti volo presso tutte e tre le
volte ho dato fuoco anche un bambino e
via d'amelio dall'avaria dalla è ancora
vivo e morta valdano cielo e ucciso da
una parte grande come il 5 la webcam vai
fa chi è mamma mi grandissimo abbiamo
fatto fuori un bosco è stato più
difficile di di didac sotto ma sei fuori
ti cedo l'onore di uscire per primo non
so se è la febbre che mi sta suicidando
il mostro sopra la corda ti sei fermato
da me sono tutti superati superò ma come
grazie a lievin venuti da fuori
alla faccia della corda però è sci e sci
e sci e sci usciamo ed è pure il suo
obbligato pure giorno fantastico reagan
che non ci posso credere in questa era
solo in mezzo l'abbiamo le corde abbiamo
qualsiasi roba andiamo a salvare teme
poi prepariamoci per il viaggio best
ever in the world che la voragine c'era
qualcosa da bere una coca come che son
bar aspetta di una fanta lemon per
favore non arriva subito sono due euro
grazie canta una moneta grazie per
favore anche allora questo bellissimo
attore di beretta così vedo che cosa c'è
intorno
ok do un'occhiata veloce
così ha aperto la valigia con delle
medicine prendere di nuovo che per te
dico merda ho iniziato a piovere poteva
andare tutto bene invece no che figata
viene vedere ma c'è l'immagine di una
dinamite come se dovessi far esplodere
sta cosa cazzo vero nuclearizzata
aspettare la spettatori ma le lancia
basse le linee non lo so
prova vai via fabriano fi e vediamo dove
ragazzi concludiamo poi l'episodio visto
che siamo andati
speriamo che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi in
classe del miur urgente sull'argomento è
un mi piace ai capace di facebook
schizzare fatemi sapere se volete
continua e noi ci rivediamo è un ex ex
da ragazzi
[Musica]